ich sag mal so wenn überziehen
kühlschranks christ 30 euro vor
damit war hier ein bisschen spannung
rein bringen
hey was geht ab und bekommen bayern ein
video ich hoffe euch jetzt gut ich bin
hier mit meinem bruder wieder der ball
schon länger nicht mehr dabei ich hoffe
dir jetzt auch gibt ja und ja zurzeit
ist ja auch auf youtube oder schon ganz
lange dieses vorteils sehr geheilt ich
hab hier noch nie ein video gemacht
einfach weg das ist noch nie gespielt
habe also ich habe wirklich ich habe
schon mal zugeguckt so aber ich habe es
noch nie selber gespielt und so wirklich
verstanden habe ich es auch nicht also
dass man sich erst mal vorweg sagen ich
hab keine ahnung davon mehr regen ist
aber echt gut darin glaube ich ne du
kannst ja mal sagen was war so das beste
was wenn ich sammle ist oder so und wird
der jedes diesen allgemeinen hast du was
kann man denn so was sind denn so werte
wo man halt so lang feststellen kann ob
man gut dass er jetzt an der allgemein
cd wissen nicht was ist eine allgemein
karte 5,05 gewann ist das gut schon also
ich habe absolut keine ahnung aber wir
gehen jetzt einmal davon aus ich habe
auch von vielen meiner freunde gerade
die schon mal mit ihm zusammen gespielt
haben das war wirklich sehr gut sein
soll und ich schaue jetzt einfach mal zu
ich kann das nicht beurteilen ich weiß
nicht was dann auch mal das ist das
heutige videospielen bisschen ford
zusammen wichtig ist auch viele spielen
ist ja auch auf der playstation und oder
ist das so kompatibel dass man
playstation und computer zusammen
spielen kann
inzwischen so leute nach einigen
aufnahmen probleme schwierigkeiten sind
wir jetzt zurück und zwar holt jetzt
hier erstmal mailings kg sehen das wirst
du ein panda maksud anders
also ich 150 kilt und ja ist jetzt vom
letzten 7
also 3 37 kg und das ist jetzt was genau
dass die kd die um dieses geld so ich
muss wartet seines pkw zurückgegangen
weil ich habe bis jetzt immer ich habe
vorhin wird im auftrag gebaut und durch
schließen jetzt komm ich dass ich ein
bisschen durch nennen aber ich das
lernen was genau richtig kennt sich
damit nicht und kann man auch sehen
deine karte von den letzten 30 tagen
weil du meinst doch gerade dass eine
firma kd jetzt würde ich mal sagen gehen
wir hier ein spiel und das spiel ist
einfach erst mal dahin dass jetzt auch
noch und dann bin ich mal gespannt und
dein bestes war in einer andere wie viel
platz 22 in einer runde ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob das gut ist oder nicht aber es
weiß ich schon gar nicht mal so schlecht
ja das ist schon gut oder wenn man
gespannt ob ich halt in der ersten runde
durch viele 320 schaffe ihr könnt ihr
auch mal in die kommentare eureka de
schreibt aber ehrlich sein welches kind
gespielt keine ahnung was los ist das
wird so schwer zu welchen charakter
diesen absoluten die okay leute dann
gehen wir jetzt ins spiel
was ist das jetzt ein modus muss man
irgendwas spezialist zu erklären
solo modus also wenn du über 10 km runde
küste ich sage mal so wenn du über zehn
kirche muss cristal 30 euro von ihr weil
etwa hier ein bisschen spannung rein
bringen was ist das denn
wie lange geht eine runde und wie viele
und wie oft hast du schon dieses winter
hcp 700 mal ist das viel
also wir gucken jetzt einfach mal hier
ein bisschen zur ich spiele einfach
weiter du machst du jetzt bluten
ja genau
so
so jetzt einmal hier 9
dann sagen wir ach ja oder sagen wir
sieben profi jetzt aber ordentlich drauf
da mit wand bauen vorher
okay nicht schlimm noch eine runde oder
wir gehen einfach mal schnell in die
nächste runde würde ich jetzt sagen wenn
sieben coaches okay du bist du krank
derzeit tut ja jetzt können dass in der
zeit welche von hinten kommen oder
jetzt können auch in der zeit welche von
hinten kommen ich weiß jetzt dicke
punkte wenn ich sie in kilts machen wenn
sterbe zuletzt 71
jetzt kommt dann hat man so schön
einfach keiner die rein texten
da linklink
hier
ich habe jetzt überhaupt ganz mehr
gecheckt aber das sagen ich war schlecht
aus daher war das kleine stimmt
und jetzt wird es am 6 spannung spannung
spannung
das ist richtig action spiel
kannst du nicht du brauchst ein paar mit
mir leben glaube ich ja jetzt habe man
gleich us dollar
naja
während deiner wie viele haben wir das
schon
ich bin richtig mitfiebern
ich habe zwar keine ahnung was er da
genau macht aber manchmal diesen weg
nicht okay
helsinki
meine firma 7 da ist jetzt erst mal 30
von mir aber sowohl soll es hier den
epischen sieger aber machen oder dauert
das so lange man noch eine runde kommen
leute eine runde geht noch sieben case
hat mir liegen ratsch gemacht das ist
das gute geld soll ja also das wäre
eigentlich der 19
ich habe nur noch den eintritten und
dann wäre es schön gewesen wenn ich acht
görg wir machen jetzt hier noch eine
runde und zwar will ich hier einmal den
epischen sieg sehen kannst mir den
jakobus 20 willst du sollst ja von ihm
geld lieber für die schule kaufen wenn
du nicht etwas für das spiel typischen
siegels schaffst du das oder ist es
schwer ja aber das mache ich schon jetzt
musst du viele kids geht jetzt erst 33
hat was ist wenn du einfach in der
letzten ecke stehen und die anderen
beiden die letzten die beiden über sind
sich auszusehen gegenseitig töten also
genau mit dem weiß wie ich meine
hast du den epischen sieg geholt aber
ich musste die ganze der zone mitlaufen
wie viele dann auch mit drin sind 88 ich
sagte ihr du konzentrierst dich einfach
darauf und ich darf hier immer sind
wieder nach insel java ist tot
jetzt sollen die zwei hirsche waren zwei
shirts
ja da spielt die musik da spielt die
musik muss dafür die musik so nur noch
27 leute drin achtung die zone wird
gleich glaube ich kleiner so langsam
wird's ernst
so gehört schon zu den 27 besten
echten epischen sich zu holen was ist
das leichten epischen 17
kommt drauf an der runde zum beispiel
schafft geschafft hast bist du schon
alles kampagne jetzt sei die justiz und
das ist was ich weiß auch dass du nicht
abgeknallt wäre es jetzt leute ich
glaube wir konzentrieren uns in diesem
video erstmal jetzt hier auf den
epischen glied und wenn er dann lust
habt dass ich das auch mal probieren
also ich hab dich ungelogen noch nie
gespielt ich will jetzt nicht oder so
ich habe da auch keine ahnung sondern
lasst mal 8000 leichter dann spüre ich
dass demnächst mal nach 18 leute da
hinten viel zu offen jetzt gerade da
oben drauf da nicht doch jeder
abschießen oder war noch viel zu oft
oben drauf da könnte ich doch jeder
abschließen
dann könnte ich bin schnell und
eliminiert jetzt aber jetzt schnell weg
sonst hätte ich da oben noch vorne weg
allerdings wächst auch immer noch leute
im game besitzt runde
ich dachte muss den epischen sich bis
jetzt weighted schon jetzt tot
schade kann man das sehen wie auch das
in epischen sieg geholt hat hast du hier
mische siege ja das war es mit dem video
oder du bist du irgendwas sagen
normalerweise müsste besser oder viel
besser sein aber das war doch schon gar
nicht so schlecht für die einen sagen ja
leute haut rein spiel nicht zu viel
computer das ist nämlich nicht gut geht
auch mal raus